time to spin the wheel here we go we're
playing the game now i believe it's
gary's turn this time
and let's spin that wheel
here we go let's see
[Music]
we've landed on ss s
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hello
gary s is four i can give you two asses
for this
i give you sour shoes and steve langford
that's the answer i was looking for sour
shoes and steve langford it's a classic
phony phone call from the very brilliant
sour shoes
if you remember steve langford was a
howard 100 news reporter
and he sat at his desk every day and
sour shoes would relentlessly call him
at his desk and just drive him
absolutely insane we're talking about
300 phone calls over but you know he was
doing a phony phone call on you
300 times if i get a call like that just
hang up
hello
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello
[Music]
well who wouldn't be annoyed by sour
shoes i mean i know that's pretty
annoying
robin could steve langford have handled
it differently
if is there something he could have done
to call off the sour shoes
relentless phony phone calls
could he have handled himself
differently i
know that it was his reaction that kept
sour shoes
calling yes
[Laughter]
but i don't know that he wouldn't have
gotten there anyway because sour shoes
was gonna call until he did
yes but threatening to call the police
was no help some might call it a prank
call right
other people might call it harassment
and against the law
listen to this steve you know what steve
does he makes the classic mistake
of like lecturing sour shoes how he's
going to go to jail and everything and
then only turns them on more hey can you
hear me
listen i just want you to know that i
want you to go to jail for this
and i will be happy to work on that
because you're insistent on committing
this crime over
and over and over again i want you to go
to jail
i mean how many people you know are
serving hard jail time for
phone calls but the thing i love
is that steve was a relentless reporter
and he didn't care how his reporting
affected you
and so i loved that sauer
was giving him hell sour
um let me say something uh if indeed
if this is you i'm calling the police
i am calling the police and they're
going to come and arrest you
see with sour shoes i think you got to
just sit there and listen and go this is
[ __ ] funny
no you're eventually going to blow
because he's never going to stop
well in steve's defense it was so hard
because he really was trying he
took his job very seriously and he
really was a good reporter
hello langford's got a huge penis
[Music]
can you hear me can you hear me uh g are
your parents there
oh my god steve i'm real busy can i call
you right back